I just got the question what it means to i
b b
I fly quite regularly i b
b especially to paramaribo where my Father lives
and I go there to take care of him
since I am also a caregiver for my Father
next to it is that I am also for my mother
who lives in the Netherlands
well ibb what does it mean
ibb it says the name says it
it is available if place
that means if there is space on board
you can for 1 edited ticket
you can join the flight
well as an example
i go to paramaribo
I then bought 1 redistributed ticket
this is no guarantee that I can still come
I GO the day of departure
1 hour before departure I bring my
Boarding pass to the gate
I hand it over to the ground staff
and they will see if there is room
if there is room then I will come along
if there is no place then I can not come
and then I can
for example try the next day
depend of course on where we fly to
try the next day try the day after
that was flying ibb
if you have any questions
ask them only once